esta es una simulación de un usuario de
khan academy llamado te espero
pronunciarlo bien que nos permite intuir
el por qué dividimos entre n menos 1
cuando calculamos la varianza de la
muestra y porque nos da un estimado in
sesgado de la varianza de la población
vamos a comenzar construyendo una
población al dar clic en el área solo
hago clic y cada vez que doy un clic
aumenta el tamaño de la población aquí
estoy dando clic salazar los invito a
que vayan a esta simulación en khan
academy en la sección de ciencias de la
computación y traten de hacer esto por
su cuenta
aquí estoy construyendo una población
dando clic aleatoriamente sobre esta
área azul y pueden ver que mientras lo
hago la simulación calcula algunos
parámetros de la población calcula la
media de la población que es de 197
puntos 6 y también la desviación
estándar de la población como pueden ver
aquí 66.6
está graficando la varianza de la
población como pueden ver aquí 66.6 al
cuadrado que es la desviación estándar
es un poco difícil de distinguir pero
aquí dice al cuadrado todos estos
números están elevados al cuadrado 66.6
al cuadrado es la varianza de la
población lo cual es interesante por sí
mismo pero no nos dice mucho hasta el
momento del por qué dividimos entre n
menos uno esta es la parte interesante
porque ahora podemos comenzar a tomar
muestras podemos decidir el tamaño de la
muestra que queremos y vamos a comenzar
con la muestra más pequeña que podamos
tener y lo que va a hacer la simulación
es que cada vez que tome una muestra va
a calcular la varianza por lo que el
numerador va a ser la suma de cada uno
de los puntos de datos de mi muestra
menos la media de la muestra y lo elevó
al cuadrado después lo vamos a dividir
entre n más a y vamos a variar la a
desde menos 3 hasta 1 por lo que el
denominador puede
desde el 3 hasta el 1
vamos a hacer esto muchísimas veces
tomamos la media de estas variantes para
cualquiera y vamos a ver cuál nos da la
mejor estimación aquí generamos una
muestra haciendo clic en el área verde
vemos esta curva roja tenemos valores
altos de a que están subestimando y
valores bajos de a que están sobre
estimando la varianza de la población
pero esto fue solamente para una muestra
y no es tan significativa ya que nuestra
muestra es de tamaño 2 ahora generaremos
muchas muestras y vamos a promediar la
mayoría de estas y verán que cuando
tenemos muchísimas muestras ocurre algo
interesante si vemos la media de estas
muestras cuando promediamos juntas estas
curvas de todas estas muestras verán que
nuestra mejor estimación está en dónde
está muy cerca de menos 1 cuando esto es
n más a negativa o n menos 1 cualquier
cosa menor que menos 1 por ejemplo n
menos 1.0 5 o n menos 1.5 comenzará
a sobreestimar la varianza y cualquier
cosa mayor que menos uno como n 0 on&on
punto 05 o lo que sea comenzaremos a
subestimar la varianza de la población
pueden hacer esto para muestras de
diferentes tamaños vamos a usar una
muestra de tamaño 16 y mientras mantengo
apretado el recuadro de generar muestra
y generamos muchísimas muestras a la vez
para todas las as tomamos el promedio de
todas las muestras para la varianza
dependiendo de cómo la estamos
calculando veremos nuevamente que
nuestra mejor estimación es aquella que
está mucho más cercana a menos 1 si
generamos millones de muestras veremos
que nuestra mejor estimación es cuando a
es igual a menos 1 o cuando dividimos
entre n menos 1 nuevamente gracias a tt
por esta simulación ya que es una forma
interesante de ver el por qué dividimos
entre n menos 1